PROFESSOR: Write w
equals sum from k
equals 0 to infinity a k rho k.
And plug in--
I've suggested that usually the
thing that you should know when
you plug in those equations
is to look for the power rho
to the k in this equation.
And just, since
everything is equal to 0,
the coefficient of rho to the
k in this equation should be 0.
And that's the easiest
way to select the powers.
That's good practice.
You should do it.
I won't do it here.
We've done it in a few cases.
So this will relate a k plus 1.
To a k.
So that's algebra.
It's a good skill
to be able to do it.
But it would be
not very good use
of our time to do it right now.
So here is the answer.
OK.
This is more important.
2 to the k plus l plus 1 minus
1 over kappa over k plus 1
plus k plus 2l plus 2.
OK.
We've got our
recursion relation.
And the issue is, again, what
happens with this coefficient
as k goes to infinity?
So as k goes large, a k plus
1 over a k goes like what?
Well, we have a k that
is becoming large,
and everything else
doesn't matter.
There's a k and a k, so there's
going to be some cancellation.
And this looks like
roughly 2 to the k.
Now, you could change
these numbers a little bit.
I'm going to do a tiny
trick to simplify it,
but it's just a trick.
Don't worry about it too much.
I'll put 2 to the k plus 1 here.
And I will say, look, if the
series diverges in this case,
this coefficient is
bigger than that one.
So it will certainly diverge
for this case, as well.
So the coefficients
here are smaller
than those ones, this ratio.
So if the ratio
between coefficients
here is such that
the series diverges,
then it will even diverge
a little more in this case.
And the reason I put it
here is because then this
is kind of solvable, a k
plus 1 nicely solvable, very
nicely solvable, 2k plus 1 a k.
And the solution
of this is to say
you can try with a 0,
what a 1 is, what a 2.
a k is 2 to the k a
0 over k factorial.
OK.
With that we can reconstruct
what kind of function
this series would be building
if the series doesn't terminate
and will not be too surprising.
So in this case, the sum
over k of a k rho k, which
is the function we're building,
is roughly equal to this
a k here, which is 2 to the k.
a 0 can go out.
k factorial rho k.
So this is a 0 e to the 2 rho.
It's kind of fair
of it to do that.
It's kind of saying that if the
w solution doesn't truncate,
it's going to go like e to
the 2 rho, which precisely
with an e to the
minus rho is going
to give you the other possible
behavior of the solutions.
It happened for the
harmonic oscillator.
So what this is saying is
that then w, which is this,
would go roughly like that.
And that's bad.
So the series must truncate.
So we must truncate the series.
OK.
So here comes the
interesting part
because there's
lots of quantities,
and that has to be done a little
slowly so that nobody gets
confused of what's
going to happen.
We have to terminate
this series.
So how are we going to do it?
I'm going to state
it the following way.
I'm going to say
that let's assume
that we want a polynomial
of degree capital N.
There will be lots of little
constants, capital N, little n.
I want a polynomial
of degree capital N.
That means that a sub capital
N is different from 0.
And a capital N plus
1 is equal to 0.
That's what should happen.
If you have constants
up to a capital N,
you'll have rho
to the capital N,
and you'll have a
polynomial of degree N.
But that must happen that
the next one must be 0.
I don't have to state
that all of the rest
are 0 because it's a
one-step recursion relation.
Once a 5 is 0, a 6, a 7,
a 8, all of them are 0.
That's it.
And we will have like
even or odd solutions
that we had for the
harmonic oscillator
because these are
functions of r.
And r and minus r you should
not quite expect anything.
Minus r doesn't exist.
So this is what should happen.
But if that happens,
think of this.
You have a n plus 1 should be 0.
So the numerator should have
become 0 for k equals 2N.
So you have one over kappa
is equal to 2N plus l plus 1.
And in a sense that's it.
Whatever had to
happen, happened.
Why?
The energy got
quantized already.
Somehow it did because
the energy is kappa.
Remember, kappa
squared actually was
the ratio of the energy divided
by the dimension [INAUDIBLE]..
So here it's saying the
energy is some number that
has to do with an
integer, which is
the degree of the
polynomial you're going
to use, an l integer, and 1.
So this is, of course,
pretty important.
So what values happen here?
What are the
possible values of l?
Well, l here, l can go
0, 1, 2, 3, all of them.
All of them are possible.
And why is that?
It's because of the
physics of the problem.
We assume we'll have a particle
in a central potential.
All values of angular
momentum can exist.
So we should be looking for
l's that take all these values.
Moreover, N is the polynomial
that you can choose.
And N can also be
all of those values.
We can begin with 0.
So a 0 would be a number.
But then it dies.
A polynomial of degree 0
would be just a constant.
It's possible.
1, 2, 3, all of
those are possible.
And for each combination
will have some energy.
But here you start
to see degeneracies,
multiple degeneracies, because
if you have the number 100,000
here, it can be built in
many, many ways, 100,000 and 1
ways or something like
that, with two integers that
have to add up to it.
And all of them will
have the same energy.
So the hydrogen atom is going
to have lots of degeneracy.
So here is a little bit of
a definition that we follow.
So all these are
allowed, all allowed,
all combinations allowed.
So l can be anything, and
capital N can be anything.
And let's define a slightly
better version of this thing.
So let's move the 2
down, 1 over 2 kappa.
That's N plus l plus 1.
And let's call all this n, or
the principal quantum number.
So n is the principal
quantum number.
And in some sense,
well, you know
that n has to be
greater or equal than 1.
It's an integer.
And has to be greater or equal
than 1 because of this 1 here
and because the other ones
cannot be negative either.
So n is a principal
quantum number,
and it's a fundamental number
because it immediately gives
you the value of the
energy, which we will
write more physically shortly.
But it hides within
it a degeneracy
that this allowed because
of these differing numbers.
So these different
numbers have to do
with the degree of the
polynomial and the value of l
that you are using.
So let's classify this and
understand it a little better.
So what do we have
for the energy?
Remember, the energy divided
by the dimensionless factor--
well, to make it
dimensionless, z squared e
squared over a 0 kappa squared.
We wrote actually that e
divided by this quantity, which
has units of energy,
was kappa squared.
So kappa squared now,
kappa is 1 over 2n.
So when we substitute here,
we get e is equal to minus
z squared e squared over
2a 0 1 over n squared.
It's probably the
most famous formula
that you certainly have studied
in high school, the 1 over n
squared of the energy
levels of the hydrogen atom.
The units are nice.
There's for z equals to 1,
there's the e squared over 2a 0
that we mentioned a little
while ago as giving you
the characteristic energy.
And e squared over
a 0 was 27.2 EV.
And therefore, e squared over
2 a 0 is the famous 13.6 EV.